you
hi everyone I'm Jenna Lee and I'm here
to talk about online Vector scheduling
in the fully Dynamic setting
this is joy to work with Ravi Shankar
Krishna Swami Varun Gupta and Saison
deep
let me Begin by defining the problem
we have M identical machines
and at each time step we're given a job
to be inserted or deleted to some
machine among these amp machines
each job has D dimensions
and we're given a positive real number
as a load in each Dimension as the input
they are n total insertions or deletions
we don't know what n is
because it's the online setting and at
each time step we're given a job
our goal is to minimize the make span
which is the maximum load over all
machines and all dimensions in our
assignment
let's look at an example
let's say we have only two machines and
two dimensions
we're given a job 1 4 as input
this means the job has load one in the
First Dimension and four in the second
dimension and let's say we insert it
into the first machine
now we want to insert job to one and we
send it to the second machine
if we want to insert job 3 1
it doesn't matter which machine we send
it to because the makes fan is going to
be 5 either way and we're going to send
it to the second machine
finally let's say we're given job seven
seven
and this job will be inserted to the
first machine because this has a lesson
expand
we have a make span of 11 with our
assignment
but it's not hard to see that a better
assignment exists where this heavy job
is present on one machine and the other
jobs are present on the second machine
and this makes man a seven
let's see what's going to happen with
deletions when we start with this
assignment which was good for us
if we want to delete this heavy job
seven seven
we're going to end up with an empty
machine so this suggests that we need
some form of reassignment of jobs
between machines and this is going to be
called recourse
this gives us our secondary goal we want
to minimize the make span
offer assignment at every time step
while ensuring that we do not use too
much records
let's look at some previous results here
in the insertion only oblivious setting
there is a randomized algorithm which
gives a competitive ratio of log B over
log log B and no recourse
in the oblivious setting we just mean
that the adversary does not have access
to the random machines by the algorithm
in the insertionally adapted setting
where the adversary can look at the
randomness used by the algorithm
there is an algorithm
which has a competitive ratio of log B
over log B same as the insertion only
oblivious setting and again no recourse
for these two settings this log D over
log log D ratio is title
next we have our result in the fully
Dynamic oblivious setting we have an
algorithm
which has a competitive ratio of log D
over log log D and constant recourse
this means that any job is reassigned a
constant number of times
throughout the existence
in the fully Dynamic adaptive setting
we give an algorithm which has a
printable ratio of log 2
and a recourse of D Times log n times
some Factor gamma
which is the factor by which so optimal
expand changes during this job's
existence
before we proceed to the algorithm let's
look at two lower Bonds on the optimal
mixed map
the first one is that the optimum expand
should be at least as high as the
average load in any dimension
this is because in the optimal
assignment there should be at least one
machine for every Dimension K where the
load exceeds the average load
and we can also say that the optimal
next fan should be higher than the
maximum load over all dimensions and all
jobs
again this is because in the optimal
assignment there should be at least one
machine for which this job is assigned
and on this machine the load is going to
be higher than this one
okay so with these two low balls the
average low low point and the maximum
load lower bound let's start by
designing some algorithms for the
insertion only setting
first we know that there is a
deterministic reading algorithm in the
single Dimension case with a constant
competitive ratio and a constant
recourse by Westbrook in 1994.
we can't use this algorithm directly
because the number of dimensions for us
is d instead we're going to do something
called flat and greedy so let's say
there are these M machines and they
already contain some jobs assigned to
them
we're given some job J which is to be
assigned to one of these machines
we're going to flatten the load in the D
dimensions of this job J into one
dimension by taking the sum of these
loads
then we're going to pick a machine which
gives the least make span based on the
sum
the competitive ratio here is going to
be D and we're not going to prove this
it's not too hard
this competitive ratio is not good for
us so let's try inserting jobs randomly
again we have these M machines and there
are already some jobs assigned to these
M machines
when we want to assign job J we're going
to just pick a random machine M of J and
assign job J to this machine
in expectation the load on each machine
is going to be ALK of J in dimension k
but the competitive ratio becomes log of
M times D because the make span may be
high and this is from turn off bound
we're now going to prove this either
in our next attempt we're going to
combine both the random algorithm and
the grid algorithms this way
we're going to assume there are two
copies of these machines called random
and 3D so there are amp machines in
random and M machines in 3D
both these copies may already have some
jobs assigned to them
we're going to set a threshold of some
order of Lambda times a l k plus maximum
load when this Lambda is the competitive
ratio that we want which is log D over
log log B
so when a job J is to be inserted we're
going to pick a random machine M of J
and just check whether on addition of
job J to machine M of J
is the threshold exceeded or not in
every dimension
this threshold is set only for the
random machine
so if this threshold is not exceeded on
addition of job J in any Dimension then
this job is going to be added to the
random set of machines
if when we're trying to insert some job
J Prime this threshold is exceeded in
some Dimension case
so let's say job J Prime was assigned to
machine 1 randomly
and this threshold is exceeded then this
job J Prime is going to be added to the
greedy set
so how we handle this green side it's
the same as the flat and greedy
algorithm that we saw earlier
we said that the competitive ratio of
this algorithm is going to be Theta of D
but
when we assign jobs this way only 1 over
D fraction of all the jobs is sent to
the greedy set and this gives a low
competitive ratio we're not going to
prove this fact now we'll prove it later
a brief sketch of this analysis of this
random plus 3D algorithm is here
so for the random machines we don't
exceed the threshold because we never
add any jobs which
go beyond this threshold
and each job is going to be sent
independently to the greedy set with
probability at most D and this is from
the choice of our threshold actual last
part
in the greedy machines
even though the competitive ratio is
Theta of D since only 1 by D fraction is
sent to them
the competitive ratio remains a constant
now
how do we change this algorithm when
jobs can be deleted as well
in the insertion only stream we know
that the optimum expand always increases
because jobs are only added
but with deletions
in the optimal weak span the average
load as the maximum load and dynamic
quantities and can increase or decrease
while we run the algorithm
to avoid this we're going to use
something called the prefix property
we're going to set the thresholds
only based on all the previous jobs
which have been inserted before job J
so the threshold for job J is going to
be the same quantitative ratio Lambda
times the average load
in dimension K till job J and the
maximum load over all Dimensions till
job J any job inserted after J does not
affect this threshold for job G
because of this our quantities ALK of J
and mL of J can only decrease
now when we want to insert job J we
again have two copies of these machines
random and PD and they already have some
jobs assigned to them we're going to set
the threshold for job J
as again order of Lambda times a l k of
J plus mL of J
so this threshold is compared to the
actual load on machine M of J
in dimension K in the random set alone
M of J is the random machine paid for
job J when we insert it
if this threshold is not exceeded when
we add job J to the random set in any
Dimension K in machine M of J then we're
going to leave it in the random set
we just want to know that this random
choice for job J is going to be fixed
when it is inserted for the first time
we never change since random assignment
as long as job J exists
if this threshold is exceeded in some
Dimension k
then job J is added to this greedy set
now where we want to delete jobs
if job J is present in the greedy set we
can just normally delete it I perform
the one dimension updates from Westbook
94 to balance the load
if job J is present in the random set
deleting it may cause some issues for us
what may happen is for some job which
was inserted after J the threshold May
decrease
because of this we perform a
stabilization procedure
as follows
if we change the thresholds and reinsert
jobs every time a job which was inserted
before us is deleted then this recourse
becomes high so instead we're only going
to update these thresholds if they draw
below half of the original factor to
change this job's assignment
so when this threshold drafts by a
multiplicative half Factor
we're going to update the threshold and
reinsert this job as if it was inserted
for the first time this is going to give
us a low recourse and a low probability
of going to the greedy set
let's see this in a bit more detail when
we want to delete job.j and it is
present in the random set we said that
threshold May decrease for jobs inserted
after G
so for some job J Prime inserted after J
we're going to check if this threshold
reduces to threshold K of J Prime by 2
for any dimension
and if this does not happen we're not
going to do anything we will just remove
job J
and proceed to the next time step
otherwise if this threshold does
decrease then we're going to recalculate
this threshold in every dimension for
this job G Prime and reinsert it in the
random set or green set appropriately If
this job J Prime was reinserted into the
random set of machines it is not going
to change its assignment because it will
be reinserted into the same machine it
was assigned to to begin with
but if it was sent to greedy it may
change its assignment and it may be
moved to the greedy set
this is our entire algorithm and now
let's look at what happens to the
recourse
pre-course is going to be constant
because a job is reassigned only when it
is shifted from random to greedy and
this happens at most once in our
algorithm
or it may be reassigned inside greedy
while we do load balancing from the
single dimensional algorithm and this is
also constant from Westbook 94 so
totally the recourse is going to be
constant
we want to prove this claim that any job
is sent to greedy with probability at
most 1 over D to prove that the
competitive ratio is going to be low
when is the job sent to greedy
if it exceeds the threshold when it was
inserted then it may be sent to greedy
without ever going to the random side
otherwise
if some job before it is deleted and
this threshold reduces by a half Factor
it may be sent to greedy well it exceeds
the threshold during this reinsertion
we will show that the probability that
this job goes to greedy is at most 1
over d
let's fix our threshold now to be some
constant 12 c times Lambda times average
load in dimension K till job J and the
maximum load then by turn off bound we
can see that the probability that this
threshold
is lower than the actual node is going
to be at most 1 by DX to C
but
this probability has this threshold
appearing in the numerator of this
exponent and we're going to use this
just a remark that we can use turn off
bound because our choice of the random
machines were independent of each other
for each of these jobs
so we have this equation we're going to
use this trick that we checked for these
thresholds only when these thresholds
were reducing by a half multiplicative
Factor so because of this if we start
with some probability we know that
totally the probability that this job is
sent to greedy by any Dimension K is
going to form a geometric series by
Union boundary
this bound is over the number of times
we try to reinsert job J because of
other deletions
the total probability does not exceed 1
by DX to C minus 1. so for any c greater
than 2 with Union bound over all
Dimensions we prove the claim
now for the competitive ratio in the
random set let's just look at the last
job which was inserted
so in dimension K we know that this load
is going to be less than the actual load
till job J was inserted along with the
maximum load before job
and this is going to be less than twice
the threshold plus the maximum load
because this job J was not moved to
greedy and this is going to be less than
the competitive ratio times are upped
directly
in the DD set we proved that only 1 by D
fraction of all the jobs are resulted in
expectation
so from wherever 94 we know that the
total load is a constant times the sum
of the average load and the maximum load
and this also is going to be only a
constant times the optimal expand
so in conclusion we gave a randomized
algorithm that handles deletions with a
log D over log log B competitive ratio
and the constant recourse
let me end with a few open questions
so we said in the insertion only setting
with oblivious adversaries this log D
over log log D bound on the competitive
ratio is tight but it's not clear if
recourse can help us beat this lower
boundary
and we don't have any records dependent
lower Bonds in the dynamic setting
say if we boundary course by some
constant what is the best competitive
ratio we can get
and it's also unclear how to extend this
algorithm to Adaptive adversaries and
reduce the records and also how to
de-randomize this
this ends my talk thank you so much for
listening